Хто стане новим господарем відомства федерального канцлера?
Знову Анґела Меркель? Чи її менш популярний
суперник Мартін Шульц від соціал-демократів все ж
надолуждить відставання?
Майже половина виборців досі не визначилися,
кому зрештою віддадуть голос.
Можна сказати, що виборці стали вибагливішими.
Те, що ми, політологи, називаємо партійною ідентичністю,
розмивається. Електорат нині гнучкіший.
Між канцлеркою та її політичним супротивником
відбудеться одна-єдина теледуель.
За свою кар’єру Меркель вже тричі виходила
на теледебати за посаду канцлера:
і тільки одного разу глядачі присудили перемогу не їй,
а тодішньому суперникові Шредеру.
Тим не менше тоді на виборах все одно перемогла Меркель.
Загалом я вважаю, що попередні передвиборчі формати
себе добре зарекомендували..
Не знаю, чому ви смієтеся... (сміх журналістів)..
Я ж не завжди перемагала за підсумками,
тож не сказала б, що мені це завжди супер вдається.
Для Мартіна Шульца теледебати - остання надія
надолужити відставання.
Соціал-демократи в рейтингах – з відривом другі. Тож, Шульц
переходить в атаку – і вдається
до особистих звинувачень на адресу канцлерки.
У вас є вибір між канцлеркою, яка уникає будь-яких відповідей щодо майбутнього
і позиція якої зводиться до того, що, мовляв, "усе добре",
"у вас є я", "цього ж достатньо".
Або кимось, хто чітко каже, чого прагне
і в якому напрямку він поведе цю країну.
Для Шульца ця теледуель важливіша,
ніж для Меркель.
На цих теледебатах завдання Мартіна Шульца -
виступити в ролі нападника
і кинути виклик канцлерці. Вона ж гратиме в захисті.
Побачимо, яким буде рахунок.
Можливо, 0:0.
У будь-якому разі -
це шанс Шульца протиставити себе канцлерці і чітко заявити
про себе як про альтернативу.
Майже 18 мільйонів людей
дивилися попередні теледебати 4 роки тому.
Для Мартіна Шульца –
це справді шанс. Якщо він ним не скористається,
багато хто просто вимкне телевізор.